you have to be fast in hiring people you
have to be fast in
uh in making decisions you have to be
fast in
executing on your marketing executing on
your
you know your product releases you just
have to you have to match your actions
with your strategy
[Music]
mike cassidy thank you for joining me on
20 minute leaders how are you
good how are you it is such an honor and
privilege to have you here thank you so
much for joining me
i know how incredibly busy you are and
and i really appreciate it i'm excited
to talk to you these 20 minutes
about really your journey and your
outlook on
on startups on deep technology on making
an impact
mike you're beside the fact that you
were a vp at google and ran
project loon which is one of my all-time
favorite
tech projects i've ever seen with trying
to provide internet
to billions of people through balloons
uh you're also
you serial entrepreneur with multiple
startups behind you
i believe one of them started with 500
dollars that you and your co-founders
put in
uh so i'd love to hear that story and
today you're running apollo fusion which
i can't wait to hear about what it is
but mike let's get started with with
real passion
which is the fact that you've released
two jazz albums
how does that work without with
everything else that i was saying
um so i love the change of pace
and um between when i do starts between
the startups i try to do something fun
and for one year between startups i was
an entrepreneur in residence at
benchmark but a different
year i went to berkeley college of music
and when i was there i studied
jazz piano and studied what it takes to
record and produce uh records and
uh and so i had fun doing that
wow unbelievable what is it about jazz
that attracted
and i have to ask this question because
i've already met
multiple really really incredible people
from the texan that are just
really love jazz my father being one of
them so what what is it about jazz that
really excites you
um i mean the improvisation part is
really fun
i think so it's you know it's not like
the same thing all the time when you get
into the improv section you're hearing
something new every time and
the act of improvisation i think is it's
a great challenge um
you know you're you've got the chords
and then
real time you're trying to make up a
melody that fits with the chords and
fits in with what the people around you
are playing there's also kind of a
camaraderie
to to jazz playing in a combo that there
is in a you know a startup you
you're listening to what every person in
the combo is doing and and
you're playing off them and they're
playing off you and i just it's very fun
for me
i love it i think one of the first
things that i was always inspired about
jazz when i started playing saxophone
very young was the idea that you have
this both the harmony
at one point where everybody's playing
together but then at some point you're
also giving
giving the stage to individual people to
showcase their creativity and you're
supporting them
and you're you're continuing to play but
but consciously supporting them so that
they're at the forefront
and giving them that chance i think i
think that's just wonderful mike
take me back to to the young days
studying aerospace engineering at
mit going then to harvard i believe but
what what is what do you what is the
trajectory that you hope for yourself
along the way what do you imagine
yourself doing later on in life
well in the beginning i wanted to be an
astronaut um but
it didn't really work out yes um but
sort of next best thing was um
i guess being an aerospace engineer and
i love being an aerospace engineer
um and i started off at this place
hughes aircraft company working on
um satellites and launch vehicles
and a solar-powered race car um
but part of that process was me kind of
feeling like
sort of the aerospace industry in those
days at least was very big and
not the fastest moving and you didn't
feel like you could have a huge
impact personally on like starting up a
startup that would then turn into a big
a big company in the air space industry
so i kind of wanted to do a startup in a
different industry where
a company could get a lot of traction
and move a lot faster
really so i mean you're talking about
how about speed and about the
the pace of the industry uh which
resonates interesting i i'd love to talk
soon about
uh speed is the primary business
strategy uh slightly
that you talked about but take me to the
days of stylists
you're starting out with your
co-founders you're putting in 500 each
a company that takes off pretty quickly
what was that journey like
give me a little bit of of the back of
the back end story
yeah so uh we're definitely capital
constrained that's for sure
um we had we had fifteen hundred dollars
plus we won the mit uh business plan
competition which was a ten thousand
dollar prize so we had
eleven thousand five hundred dollars um
and it really forced us to be
what did they say uh necessity is the
mother of invention
i mean every every step of the way be
super frugal super careful
um and as we launch this this software
product
um we literally every day on the wall we
put how much
how much profit did we make today we
didn't put what our sales were
how much profit did we make and we sort
of trained our whole company wow
focus on profit and then we would make
little rules for ourselves like okay
before we can hire a tech support person
we need to have
uh three weeks where the total profit
each week
is at least ten thousand dollars and
then once that happened we'd okay
now can hire a tech support person and
that i think that discipline
helped the whole company focus on the
right things
how do you how do you focus on that
discipline because it sounds to me from
talking to a lot of young entrepreneurs
and looking at myself
that's one of the hardest things to do
is to have that bigger picture that
vision
overarching strategy of understanding
what it will take to
to continue growing where do you get
that discipline at such an early time
this is i believe one of the first
the first endeavors that you run by
yourself right
well i think it was kind of forced on us
i mean we were like
um had to focus on the fundamentals uh
you know who is going to buy we had this
idea for a piece of software
software tool who was going to buy it we
sort of figured we had some ideas on
that
and then what is our sort of marketing
distribution
channel and it was very simple for us
there was
a computer telephony journal one
magazine it was focused on
telephony and then there was something
called visual basic programmers journal
basically a medium for people using
visual basic
and our tool was a visual basic tool to
do computer telephony so we focused on
those two channels
and we focused on like like pr
we got we got on the cover of computer
telephony magazine twice
over the course of uh about a year we
focused on
basic advertising we would take out a
you know a thousand dollar ad and
in one of these magazines then we would
see okay we got three thousand dollars
back
okay maybe maybe we can try two thousand
dollar ad and we get you know nine
thousand back and we just the
the basics and it really was the basis
i love it i love it and and the next
endeavor direct hit
500 days 500 million dollar acquisition
and obviously it's not just about the
money but it's also the impact but but
that
that makes me think a lot about about
your presentation
speed is the primary business strategy
you're coming from an industry where
you're saying that you know it's not
necessarily moving the fastest you're an
early
young entrepreneur out of mit in harvard
where
what is this thinking process behind
speed as the primary business strategy
what does that even mean to you
um well i mean i think speed brings a
lot of advantages
first of all you can it's easier to
attract people to join your adventure
when you can point to how fast you're
moving
um like one of the companies was it was
an instant messenger for pc video gamers
and if we could say
you know in the in a a month ago
we gained in the past month you know we
gained
2 million new users the month before
that we gained a million new users
that gets people to say wow i want to
join your company or when you're raising
money
if you can show those kind of statistics
it's easier to raise money
um when you're getting press to cover
you it's easier to get the press
to cover you it's also tougher for your
competition to keep up with you i mean
we had competitors
right who were releasing we were
releasing a new a new version of the
product
um basically every two weeks every two
weeks a new version would come out
and some of our competitors were
releasing a new version of their product
every year so it was much easier for us
at a two-week cycle to
to basically just destroy them from a
feature comparison standpoint
what does that mean today to to yeah go
ahead
well so i think i mean i think the speed
you know brings a lot of advantages from
a
competitive standpoint and then you just
have to execute in that in everything
you do
you have to be fast in hiring people you
have to be fast in
uh in making decisions you have to be
fast in
executing on your marketing executing on
your
you know your product releases you just
have to you have to match your actions
with your strategy
right so you're really looking at speed
as a strategy
and not just not just as an advantage
but actually something that that
that the leadership of a company should
put forward as one of their key
motivations
in their day-to-day right and because
because it it it all comes down to
culture and and
how everybody's aligned towards what are
the milestones
and i'm i'm seeing it now within a very
fast-growing company hippo
how we're all feeling the pace and
everybody's aligned towards the these
this amazing mission and we know that
every day counts which is really
incredible
mike i have to talk about project loon
because it's it's one of my
favorite all-time projects i remember
seeing the videos of the balloons and
and just thinking about you know how
creative that is and the impact that it
can do
you joined google to help run it but
tell me a little bit about the
motivations behind project loon
and really all around what it takes to
run
a moonshot idea like this
yeah so loon was it was a very very fun
crazy challenging adventure um
when we started on it pretty much 95
percent of everyone heard of it thought
it was never going to work and it was
crazy
um we had to do a lot of things we had
to
basically shrink a cell tower
uh to be much much lighter much smaller
and much use much less power because
that's we're basically putting on a
balloon
we had to find ways of of steering the
balloons
and people didn't think you could steer
really
uh you know these balloons at sixty
thousand feet you could you didn't have
a motor on it you know to
just to you know propel it around but in
in the um in the stratosphere the wind
direction is stratified so
at sixty one thousand feet the wind
might be going 5 miles an hour east
at 59 000 feet it might be going 12
miles an hour south
so by just going up and down you can
steer north east west
south and west and those little keys to
you know tactical whatever design
advantages
eventually got us to the point where we
could launch you know a couple dozen
balloons from puerto rico
and two weeks later having them hovering
all over a spot of
you know a few dozen square miles in
peru
and so it's just a theories of solving
technical technical challenges
i just love that and give me a little
bit of background as to why project loon
um came about so obviously we're talking
about accessibility
we're talking about a creative way to
provide accessibility
for for places in the world can you give
me a little bit of context as to how
many people
still are not don't have access to
internet why does google x
put so many resources into this crazy
creative project
yeah um so you know when we were
starting
something on the order of half of the
people in the world didn't have internet
access
um you go to africa there's a billion
people in africa
only 100 million had internet access
even when we were starting even in india
over a billion people only about 100
million
had internet access so there were lots
and lots of people who didn't have
access
and some of it was very straightforward
uh in in the more urban areas
there were cell towers and it was cost
effective for the telephone companies to
build cell towers but a lot of times in
the more
rural areas it was not cost effective
and a lot of people in the rural areas
just didn't have cell towers um so that
was kind of the thinking
and then of course all the things all
the benefits the internet brings
you know weather reports and education
and medical information
and commerce um so that was kind of the
driver
behind the idea that that's incredible
and now
you're coming in to project loon you've
had i believe four
stars behind you working in other
companies previously
and now you're running a team that it's
not really clear whether this is going
to succeed
there is no crazy no pro there's no
profit at the end of the day that you're
marking on the board to know your growth
you're really solving a huge technical
problem that at the end could
potentially impact billions of people
what is this what is the leadership
mindset that you have to take
into this that is perhaps either
different or similar to your previous
endeavors
um well i mean i still believed that
that moving very quickly was the right
strategy for loon
um i mean there's competition in the
world i mean you can just look around
today you see
um multiple satellite um constellations
uh you know spacex's starlink uh you
know one web
you know telesat has announced one
amazon has announced one
um so yeah they're trying to do similar
things bring internet to many people so
you gotta you gotta move to beat the
competition um but also
got to move quickly just to avoid
i don't know the project kind of
petering out if it goes on too many
years
without success you know google might
decide they don't want to continue to
fund it
people on the team might decide it's not
interesting enough they might drift off
the team so i think there's still
advantages
or necessity in many cases to um to
moving quickly even even in a you know
corporate environment like that
right and in 2017 you go back to
to the entrepreneurial days creating a
new venture apollo fusion
again in the aerospace field why
leave vp at google a dream position that
you know millions of people want you've
had these experiences before right you
know what it's like being an
entrepreneur
people say that you have to be crazy to
be an entrepreneur why go
and create a new venture
uh i mean i just love the camaraderie of
the
startup environment and i love the um
you know the small team that you know we
have 20 people now at
apollo fusion i just love that sort of
size um
and uh it's it's more what i'm used to
it's sort of a small small
small company um yeah it's been more
what i'm used to
so what's the mission because also
apollo fusion is trying to solve some
pretty
some pretty incredible problems that are
extremely relevant to 2020 especially
what we've seen with with environmental
changes
um yeah i i it's very fun time to be in
the space business
um it's kind of like the second base
boom you know space renaissance or
something the 60s
very exciting with the apollo program
and a lot of attention focused on it i
think
over a few decades the interest kind of
died down a little bit you know the
space
shuttle program ended um right
to be kind of bogged down but some of
the things we mentioned before
like you know with with with spacex
being able to
you know offer a much cheaper payload uh
you know dollars per kilogram to orbit
um with you know using
various cell phone type technology to
make small satellites you know you talk
about
you know the inertial measurement unit
inside a cell phone you can use that on
a satellite yeah you can use a cpu from
a cell phone you can use that on the
satellite so you can drive the cost of
the satellites down
the the cost launch cost is going down
and there's a lot of uses right there's
the internet bringing communication uses
but there's also earth observation
you know a lot of people are interested
in uh you know using the satellites to
um you know track where
you know forests are getting burned or
where
there's illegal fishing going on or you
can you know detect
um climate change and or or from a
you know uh from a competitive
standpoint you can you can measure sort
of what's going on in the competitive
landscape and you can use that
information uh to
to make your company faster and better
a hundred percent 100 mike i have you
know going over
this incredible journey you know most of
the people that are watching this are
young entrepreneurs young engineers that
are excited to go on their journey
one of the things that i mentioned that
i'm incredibly inspired by is solving
really difficult problems that that have
a huge impact
potential huge impact later on what are
some insights that you've gained over
the years that you would tell either
yourself as a young entrepreneur or
or other young you know hungry
entrepreneurs that are just thinking
about how to get started
what are some really main things that
you that you would keep in mind
yeah so it was either larry or sergey
who once pointed out to me that
um you know all startups are going to be
very hard
so if they're all going to be hard why
don't you go after something big
you know anyway which at first i was
like that's kind of crazy but it's
i think it's kind of true um yeah i
think um
i think i'm really a big fan of
you know focusing on the right
general industry to be in you know like
uh in the in the 80s you want to be in
you know personal computers you know in
the
in the late 90s you want to be in the
internet type businesses you know right
now you might want to be the space
business or you might want to be in
you know crispr or biotech or something
like that so focus on the right space to
be in
you know whatever is a rising tide rises
all ships or whatever
um but then also uh
you know four out of the five companies
i had had to change direction
from the original the original idea so
um maybe i'm not so good at picking the
first idea but
but putting together a really you know a
plus team
that can pivot quickly and get in the
right space
get get started and i'm always
encouraging entrepreneurs get started
get a good team together
start out put your whatever your
whatever your your prototype out there
you're in
whatever you call the um initial um
product whatever um put it out there and
click okay
yeah um get get feedback and then adjust
that happened four out of five times we
got feedback saying that's the wrong
direction
but by the way near near what you're
doing there's something that's much more
interesting and so
shift over that near thing so yeah i
definitely encourage entrepreneurs to
to do that 100 i love the mentality i
see i see quite a few people that are
getting get so excited about this idea
they do get an a plus team but then they
run off for about a year year and a half
perfecting that idea
only to realize that there are some
really dramatic pivots because they
never
had any any any initial validation but
by providing this
you know 50 percent mvp to the world and
prototyping just to see reactions and
pivoting quickly
saves so much time and obviously capital
mic thank you so much for
for being here this is so great to have
you and thank you for being generous
with your time
before we leave i have to ask the most
important question which is
three words that you would use to
describe yourself
uh okay number one is tenacious
um i think it was um
thomas edison who said if you for faced
with like
failure again and again what's the
surest way to succeed is to always be
willing to try just one more time
and it seems like a little whatever a
little simple thing but if you think
about it it's kind of true right i mean
if you're always
being willing to try it just one more
time
uh then you'll never by definition fail
um
the second one i guess would be
optimistic i mean i think other people
have said this
i think it's a it's a very
characteristic trait of entrepreneurs
that they're irrationally optimistic i
think i'm definitely irrational
optimistic
um but you know you kind of need that
to do to be an entrepreneur 100
yeah that's good and then the last one i
think maybe be
open um i'm very open at the company
i tell the team when things are going
great and when they're not going great
but at least that way they believe me i
think that's a bad ceo trade to always
be saying
everything's great nobody believes you
so you gotta you gotta be open and tell
people you know what's going on
mike thank you very very much and this
was this was phenomenal i can't wait to
follow polo fusion some more
and stay safe and stay healthy thank you
for having me
and uh say hi to your dad for me okay
bye
you